ALEX, A 42nd START.
TIEDVE
COVERAGE IN THE DETROIT, ON THE
IT COMES FOR LUCAS RAYMONON GET
OESTERLE, LA A
CHANGE, RED WINGS KEEP IT IN.
A BROKEN STICK ISSIDER.
IN FRONT OF THE NET.
WHAT A  THE
FIRST INTERMISSION.
IT.
DECIDED IT WASN'T TO BE.
AND THE FANS DON'T AGR TRIP FOR.
IMPINGE WITH PEACE IN THE EAST
FORS LONG
>> JORDAN OESTERLE BACK.
TAMPAA BRIAN ISSED
IT.
GOT IT BACK TO THE  HIGH
SLIDE.
>> BRIAN ELLIOTT ON
SUNDQVIST
JAKE WALMAN, SAVED BY
1-0. AMEK
PAUL SCORED AT CARAR
SOME MISTAKES HERE.
>> ON THE WING FOR GREAT CHANCE.
SHORT-HANDED.
HOOKING THE CALL FROM CH 22 MIN
THIS AFTERNOON.  GOAL
LI TO THE FOREHAND.
THE GOALTENDER LEFT.
THOU THE
COUPLE.
HELP FROM SAM GAGNER.
LIGHTNING ABLE TO R.
THE STATEANDREW MCCUTCHEN BACK.
SUCH A GOOD --POINT.  ANTHONY M.
>> WE
NIKITA KUCHEROV WANTS THE POINT
IN THE MIDDLE.
HEOINT IN THE